de la 27ème conférence pour le climat en
Égypte près de 200 chefs d'État du monde
entier réunis dans un contexte d'urgence
climatique la terrasse d'un fast-food en
plein Paris prise d'assaut par des
militants déguisés en poulet l'opération
coup de poing est menée par le collectif
L214 son objectif dénoncer des
conditions d'élevage jugées inhumaines
la cop27 doit être le lieu pour combler
le déficit d'ambition le déficit de
crédibilité et le déficit de solidarité
à Toulouse un match du Top 14 est
interrompu par deux militants dans leur
viseur la politique du gouvernement et
un chiffre sur leur T-shirt 872 comme le
nombre de jours selon eux avant que les
effets du dérèglement climatique ne soit
tirés Bercy Jean-Luc Mélenchon quelle
question
c'est quand est-ce qu'on déjeune
ensemble OK
les actions chocs en France et en Europe
dans l'aéroport d'Amsterdam c'est jet
privé resteront cloué au sol la faute à
ses dizaines de militants écologistes il
réclame la diminution du trafic aérien
pourquoi ne pas déclarer l'état
d'urgence écologique c'est la question
que me pose Marie-Ange dans le courrier
qu'elle vient de m'adresser que je suis
en train de lire et comme beaucoup
d'autres
c'est un courrier qui m'interroge
puis-je éligible aux nouveaux chèques
énergie un chèque de 100 à 200 euros en
fonction des revenus et du nombre de
personnes de votre foyer je voulais vous
proposer de m'adresser très directement
vos questions sur ce sujet soit par
commentaire en suivi de cette vidéo soit
en postant vous-même une vidéo afin de
me poser votre question de me faire part
de vos réflexions il y a pas eu de
profiteur dans l'inflation de
l'inflation dans l'alimentaire Bruno Le
Maire est affirmatif dans une interview
parisien vous pouvez vous rendre sur le
site chaque énergie.gouv.fr un
simulateur permet de vérifier votre
éligibilité enfin si votre cuvée déjà
rempli il faudra attendre le prochain
ravitaillement pour dépenser ce chèque
ou bien l'utiliser pour payer votre
facture d'électricité après le qu'il
retourne en Afrique hier c'est le
conseiller spécial de Marine Le Pen
Philip Olivier qui a créé la controverse
en qualifiant le député de la France
insoumise manuel Bompard
clochard le ministre qui confirme aussi
que la ristourne des 30 centimes sur le
carburant ne sera pas prolongée elle
tombera à 10 centimes le 15 novembre
c'est une nouvelle démonstration du fait
que la soi-disante des diabolisation du
rassemblement national n'est qu'un
leurre et qu'en réalité ça reste un
parti raciste vulgaire agressif violent
ce sont des propos racistes je le dis
très clairement quand tu étais tenu dans
l'hémicycle voit qu'on a une question
sur le singulier ou le pluriel il n'y a
pas de racisme light il n'y a pas de
racisme présentable il y a le racisme et
puis un signal qui est donc ensuite été
sanctionné exclusion temporaire de 15
jours de l'Assemblée privation pendant
deux mois de la moitié de son indemnité
parlementaire fait il a eu la sanction
qui est la plus haute possible prévue
par le notre règlement intérieur c'était
ce que nous avions demandé et moi je
suis vous voyez là contente que cette
sanction était prononcée à l'unanimité
du bureau la sanction est juste et
justifiée et l'événement politique
modèle qui n'a pas été suffisamment
commenté c'est que la droite
républicaine et les centriste ce sont
solidarisés de de cette protestation
j'irai plus que c'est sa proposition à
la fois de pouvoir mettre à jour la
liste des métiers en tension en retirer
lorsque les médecines sont plus en
tension inclure la restauration ministre
du Travail de faire son travail avec les
partenaires sociaux je ne vais pas
manger sur ces plates bien évidemment
Éric Zemmour une question
quelle horreur
ça c'est une affirmation que vous
reprocher le rassemblement national en
disant c'est un plan de régularisation
et ce n'est pas un plan de
régularisation et j'ai entendu Madame Le
Pen qui pendant la campagne expliquait
elle-même elle parlait pas de
régularisation elle parlait de
naturalisation des étrangers qui sont
utiles pour le pays il vit vraiment
quand est-ce qu'il va consulter un psy
quoi non pardon mais ça a été sprinter